Speaking of psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning one of our favorite episodes from the past year. In February, I talked to University of California Berkeley psychologist Alison Gopnik about how children's amazing brains are optimized to explore the world, and the implications that has for human evolution, how we parent our kids, the role of grandparents in raising children, and more. I hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of psychology, we'll be back with a new episode next week. Thank you for listening. As a species, we humans have an extra long childhood. Our closest primate relatives are more or less self-sufficient by about age seven,
《Speaking of Psychology》正在进行暑期休假，因此我们将重播过去一年中最受欢迎的一期节目。今年二月，我采访了加州大学伯克利分校的心理学家艾莉森·高普尼克（Alison Gopnik），探讨了儿童神奇的大脑是如何为了探索世界而进行优化的，以及这对于人类进化、我们如何养育孩子、祖父母在抚养孩子中的角色等方面意味着什么。我希望你能喜欢这期来自档案的节目。《Speaking of Psychology》下周将带着新节目回归。感谢您的收听。作为一个物种，人类拥有一个超长的童年。我们最近的灵长类亲戚在大约七岁时就基本能够自立了，
nearly a decade before human kids are ready to face the world on their own. And as any parent or caregiver knows, children are costly. They take an extraordinary amount of time, energy, and resources to raise. Children are not simply messier and less sophisticated versions of adults either. A baby's brain has unusual capabilities. It's optimized to explore the world and seek new knowledge and experiences. Knowing this has implications for how we think about the purpose of childhood and how we raise and educate our children,
这比人类儿童准备好独自面对世界要早将近十年。正如任何父母或看护者所知，养育孩子代价高昂。抚养他们需要耗费大量的时间、精力资源。而且，儿童绝不仅仅是成年人那种更混乱、更不成熟的版本。婴儿的大脑拥有不同寻常的能力。它经过优化，能够探索世界并寻求新的知识和体验。了解这一点，对于我们如何看待童年的目的、如何养育和教育儿童，
even how we might develop artificial intelligence inspired by children's remarkable learning abilities. So why do we humans have such a long childhood? What's in it for us as a species? What can we learn about our adult selves by looking at kids' brains? looking at kids' brains, and is there anything we adults can do to become more open, curious, and childlike in our thinking? How might that be beneficial? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links
甚至如何开发受儿童卓越学习能力启发的AI都具有深远的意义。那么，为什么人类会有如此漫长的童年？这对于我们这个物种来说意味着什么？通过观察孩子们的大脑，我们能对自己成年后的状态了解到什么？而且，我们这些成年人在思维上是否能做些什么，变得更加开放、好奇和富有童心？这会有什么益处？欢迎收听《Speaking of Psychology》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Allison Gopnik, a professor of psychology and an affiliate professor of philosophy at the University of California, Berkeley. She studies how children learn and come to understand the world around them. Over her four-decade career, she's published more than 100 journal articles and many books, including her most recent The Gardener and the Carpenter, what the new science of child development tells us about the relationship between parents and children. She's also written widely about topics including play, schooling, the relationship between grandparents and grandchildren, artificial intelligence, and much more that we'll try to touch on today if we can.
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是艾莉森·高普尼克博士，她是加州大学伯克利分校的心理学教授兼哲学兼职教授。她研究儿童如何学习并理解周围的世界。在她四十年的职业生涯中，她发表了100多篇期刊文章和许多书籍，包括她最新的《园丁与木匠：儿童发展的新科学告诉我们父母与孩子之间的关系是什么》。她还广泛撰写了关于游戏、学校教育、祖父母与孙辈关系、人工智能等众多主题的文章，如果时间允许，我们今天都会尽量涉及。
Thank you for joining us, Dr. Gopnik. Happy to be here. You have written that kids are the R&D, the Research and Development Division of Humanity. That's a really great image. Can you tell us what you mean by that? Well, one of the interesting puzzles, as you mentioned, is why is it that we have such a long period of childhood?
感谢您做客我们的节目，高普尼克博士。很高兴来到这里。您曾写道，孩子们是人类的研发（R&D）部门。这是一个非常棒的比喻。您能跟我们谈谈这是什么意思吗？嗯，正如你所提到的，其中一个有趣的谜题是，为什么我们会有这么长的童年期？
Why is it that, you know, not to put too fine a point on it, our babies are useless. In fact, you could argue they're sort of worse than you. because we have to put so much time and energy into taking care of them. And that's a kind of evolutionary puzzle. And it turns out that if you look across many different species, you see this relationship between how long a period of childhood an animal has and essentially how smart, how good they are at learning as adults.
为什么，你知道的，话虽如此，我们的婴儿简直是“无用”的。事实上，你甚至可以说他们某种程度上还不如你，因为我们必须投入大量的时间和精力来照顾他们。这是一个进化上的谜题。事实证明，如果你观察许多不同的物种，你会发现动物童年期的长短与它们成年后的聪明程度、学习能力之间存在着这种联系。
So you see this not just for humans, but you see it among primates. You even see it among birds. So that, for instance, ravens and crows are very, very smart birds. and they have a much longer period, fledgling periods than other less intelligent birds. So that raises the question, what is it that that period is doing? Is there some function it's serving that makes it worth the cost of taking care of those helpless babies? And the best explanation we have is that there's a kind of trade-off between different kinds of things that a brain or a mind can do. In artificial intelligence, they talk about this is the explore,
所以你不仅在人类身上看到这一点，在灵长类动物中也能看到。你甚至在鸟类中也能看到。例如，渡鸦和乌鸦是非常非常聪明的鸟类，它们的雏鸟期比其他不太聪明的鸟类要长得多。这就引发了一个问题：这段时期究竟在做什么？它是否在发挥某种功能，使得照顾这些无助婴儿的代价变得物有所值？我们所拥有的最佳解释是，大脑或心灵能够执行的不同功能之间存在着某种权衡。在人工智能领域，他们称之为“探索与利用”的权衡，
exploit trade-off. And the idea is that it's you can't really have a system that's both really, really good at doing things and really, really good at learning things. Because the things that you need to be effective at acting, having very narrow focus, acting very swiftly, only considering a couple of options at a time, those are all the things you need to, you know, sort of be an executive, go out and make things happen. And they're very different from the kinds of things that you need to be able to take in as much information as you can from the world, consider as many different possibilities as you can, go out and explore and take risks just for the sake of getting information.
其核心思想是，你无法真正拥有一个既擅长做事又擅长学习的系统。因为你需要具备有效行动的能力——比如非常狭窄的专注力、极快的反应速度、一次只考虑几个选项——这些都是成为一个执行者、走出去让事情发生所需要的所有特质。这与你需要从世界中尽可能多地吸收信息、尽可能多地考虑不同的可能性、为了获取信息而出去探索和冒险所需的特质截然不同。
Those two things are really genuinely in tension with one another. And what I've argued is that childhood is evolution's way of resolving that tension. So childhood gives us this period where we can just explore. And the reason why we can do it is because the one thing that babies are really good at is being as cute as they could possibly be. that makes everybody else around them want to put in the time and work and investment of taking care of them. And then that period lets an animal explore learn in a kind of free-ranging way. And then, of course, as an adult, you can take the things that you learned in that childhood period
这两者之间确实存在着真正的张力。而我所论证的是，童年是进化解决这种张力的方式。童年给我们提供了这样一个时期，让我们只需去探索。而我们能够做到这一点的原因在于，婴儿最擅长的一件事就是尽其所能地可爱，这使得他们周围的其他所有人都愿意投入时间、工作和投资来照顾他们。然后，这段时期让动物能够以一种自由漫游的方式进行探索和学习。当然，作为一个成年人，你就可以将在童年时期学到的东西付诸实践，从而能够进行我们作为成年人所做的所有规划、行动和执行功能。
and actually put them to use to be able to do all the kind of planning and action and executive function that we do as adults. What do you think it feels like to be a kid and have your mind in this exploratory state all the time? Is there anything that we experience in adulthood that might come close? Yeah, so it's a really good question about, you know, what is it like to be a baby? There's a famous paper by the philosopher Thomas Nagel about what is it like to be a bat and what is it like to be a baby. And again, I think, you know, part of the big picture of the point of the work that I've done is it's very easy for people to think about babies. as if they're sort of defective grown-ups. The way to think about development is,
你认为作为一个孩子，让你的思维一直处于这种探索状态是什么感觉？我们在成年期经历的任何事情能接近这种状态吗？是的，这是一个非常好的问题，关于“作为一个婴儿是什么感觉”。哲学家托马斯·内格尔（Thomas Nagel）曾写过一篇著名的论文，探讨当一只蝙蝠是什么感觉，以及当一个婴儿是什么感觉。同样，我认为我所做的工作的一个宏观角度是，人们很容易把婴儿看作是有缺陷的成年人。看待发展的正确方式是：
okay, there's this absolute marvelous peak of human development, which is being, I don't know, the 30-year-old philosopher who's writing the article. And then everything else is just sort of building up to that or else falling off from that later on when you become an old lady the way I am now. But of course, from an evolutionary perspective, that doesn't make very much sense, right?
好吧，人类发展有一个绝对绝妙的巅峰，那就是，我不知道，比如那个正在写文章的30岁哲学家。然后其他的一切都只是为了达到这个巅峰，或者在后来你变成像我现在的这种老太太时从巅峰跌落。当然，从进化的角度来看，这并没有多大意义，对吧？
And you can see that in discussions about consciousness too. So there's been this sort of idea that, you know, the 35-year-old philosopher in his armchair is the peak of consciousness and when he's sitting there thinking about consciousness, that's the greatest kind of consciousness you could have. So that means that babies who are obviously not doing that sort of thing must be less conscious than adults. But I think there's a good argument we made that babies are actually more conscious than adults. And the reason is if you think about what the function of their, the functional characteristics of their experience, the fact that they're learning a lot,
你在关于意识的讨论中也能看到这一点。因此曾有过这样一种观点，即安乐椅上的那个35岁的哲学家是意识的巅峰，当他坐在那里思考意识时，那就是你可能拥有的最伟大的意识。这意味着那些显然没有在做那种事情的婴儿，一定比成年人意识更不活跃。但我认为有充分的理由可以证明，婴儿实际上比成年人更具意识。原因在于，如果你考虑他们的体验的功能特征——他们正在学习大量东西，
the fact that everything around them is new, even the fact that when you look at their brains, there's a tremendous amount of plasticity, as neuroscientists say, a lot of change going on. All that fits with the picture that they're actually more open to more of what's going on in the world around them than we typically are when we're adults sort of stuck in our little narrow internal paths.
他们周围的一切都是新的，甚至当你观察他们的大脑时，正如神经科学家所说，存在着大量的可塑性，有大量的变化在发生。所有这些都符合这样一种图景：他们实际上比我们成年时（通常陷入狭隘的内在小路中）更开放，能接触到周围世界中更多正在发生的事情。
And I think they're, you know, for instance, kind of classic, Buddhist psychology has pointed out this contrast between the way we think when we're just into our own heads and focused on one specific thing and the way that in some kinds of meditative states like open awareness states, for example, we're suddenly open to everything that's going on around us. We're aware of everything around us. I think another example is travel for adults. So when you go to a new place, you are not very functional. You don't, you often, you know, at least like me, you leave your, you know, you leave your, your charger in five different places and you're not, it's really stressful to even get from, you know, your hotels at the conference center. But on the other hand, you're, you're much more aware of everything that's going on around you. And, you know, those couple of days in the new place in Beijing or Paris feel as if they're full of consciousness in a really deep, important way that, that it's not like your
我认为它们，例如，经典的佛教心理学指出了这样一种对比：一种是我们只沉浸在自己的脑海中、专注于某一件特定事情时的思维方式；另一种是在某些冥想状态下，比如开放觉知状态下，我们突然对周围发生的一切都保持开放。我们意识到周围的一切。我认为另一个例子是成年人的旅行。所以当你去一个新的地方时，你的功能并不是很好。你往往，你知道的，至少像我一样，你会把充电器落在五个不同的地方，甚至从酒店走到会议中心都会感到压力重重。但另一方面，你对周围发生的一切要敏锐得多。而且，你知道的，在北京或巴黎新地方的那几天，感觉充满了意识，以一种非常深刻、重要的方式，这是不同于你
everyday experience. And then the most recent thing that I think might be revealing about this is that there's some recent work that suggests that people under the effects of certain kinds of psychedelic substances, that, you know, there's been a great deal of work recently about kind of renaissance of work on psychedelics and their potential effects. And the brain effects of those looks like from the new studies that the brain effects of those substances are a lot like putting the brain back into its childhood state, the state of a great deal of plasticity and not very much control, not very much frontal control. And again, that's sort of, you know, if you sort of think about, I think everybody who's
日常生活体验的。我认为最近能揭示这一点的事情是，最近有一些工作表明，在某些迷幻物质影响下的人们——你知道，最近有大量关于迷幻及其潜在效果的复兴研究。从新研究来看，这些物质对大脑的影响看起来很像让大脑回到其童年状态，即具有巨大可塑性且控制力不强、额叶控制不强。再次强调，如果你仔细想想，我想每一个见
seen a baby has had that experience of thinking, gee, that baby is just really out there, right? You watch the baby looking at their hands or looking at their mobile and thinking this is the most amazing thing in the world. Everything's a discovery. of fits, that's right. So that the babies seem to be more tuned into even little details of the world around them, even though they don't have the kind of focused internal, all right, here's what I'm going to do tomorrow, here's what I'm going to do the day after that, that we do with adults. You've talked about how children's brains are lanterns of consciousness while adult brains are like
过婴儿的人都有过这种感觉，天哪，那个婴儿真的是状况外，对吧？你看着婴儿看着自己的手或看着他们的婴儿床铃，觉得这是世界上最神奇的事情。每一样东西都是一个发现，这完全符合这一点。因此，婴儿似乎更能调动自己去关注周围世界的微小细节，尽管他们没有成年人那种专注的内部计划——比如，好吧，明天我要做什么，后天我要做什么。你曾谈到过，孩子的大脑是意识的灯笼，而成年人的大脑就像
spotlights of consciousness. That's what you're talking about here, right? And what do you mean by that? Exactly. So the metaphor about attention for example, being a spotlight. That's a very old metaphor in cognitive psychology. And there's lots and lots of evidence to suggest that that's true. So for adults. So there's even your listeners probably know about the famous guerrilla experiment where there's a phenomenon called inattentional blindness,
意识的聚光灯。这就是你在这里谈论的内容，对吧？你这是什么意思？完全正确。例如，关于注意力的聚光灯隐喻。这是认知心理学中一个非常古老的隐喻。有大量证据表明这是真的，特别是对于成年人来说。你的听众可能甚至知道著名的“大猩猩实验”，其中有一种现象叫做“无意盲视”，
which means that we as adults literally don't see things that we're not paying attention to. So if someone says, okay, here's, you know, two people and they're throwing balls back and forth, And I want you to concentrate on how many times did the ball move. And then a gorilla walks right through the middle of the screen. People literally don't see the gorilla, which is sort of amazing. But it gives you a sense of how narrow and bright that spotlight is. And I think if you look at babies and young children, you're not seeing that kind of inattentional blindness. The focus of what the babies are doing is much wider.
这意味着我们作为成年人，字面意义上看不到那些我们没有去注意的东西。所以如果有人说，好吧，这里有两个人，他们正在来回扔球，我想让你集中注意力数一数球移动了多少次。然后一只大猩猩直接从屏幕中间走过。人们字面意义上根本看不到那只大猩猩，这真是太神奇了。但这让你对那个聚光灯是多么狭窄和明亮有了切身的体会。我想如果你观察婴儿和幼儿，你不会看到那种无意盲视。婴儿在做的事情，其关注范围要广泛得多。
And of course, that has some disadvantages. Like it's hard for babies to pay attention or to concentrate. But, you know, one of the things I say is when we say that children are bad at paying attention, what we really mean is they're bad at not paying attention. So what they're bad at is filtering out all the other kinds of things that are going on around them, that fascinating little, you know, piece of dust on the floor or the sound of that airplane high up in the sky that we grownups don't even notice. They're bad at not paying attention to those things and just paying attention to the thing
当然，这也有一些缺点。比如婴儿很难集中注意力或聚精会神。但是，你知道，我常说的一句话是，当我们说孩子不擅长集中注意力时，我们真正想说的是他们不擅长“不去”集中注意力。所以他们不擅长过滤掉周围发生的其他所有事情，比如地板上那个迷人的小尘埃，或者是我们成年人甚至都注意不到的高空中飞机的声音。他们不擅长忽略那些事情，只去关注
they're supposed to be paying attention to, like putting on their jacket to get to school. So in recent years, you've become interested in the other end of the lifespan as well. I know you've written about in addition to our having long childhoods that humans also have unusually long old age. And you believe that both of these factors are critical to human intelligence and adaptability. Why is that? So there's two things that are really interesting about this. One is, as we know, humans have this long, essentially grand-
他们本该关注的事情，比如穿上夹克去上学。因此，近年来，你也开始对生命周期的另一端感兴趣。我知道你曾写过，除了我们拥有漫长的童年之外，人类还拥有异常漫长的老年。而且你认为这两个因素对人类的智力和适应能力都至关重要。这是为什么呢？
motherhood, this post-menopausal period of about 20 years, which really makes us different from our closest primate relatives and makes us different from for most other animals. And that's always been true. That was true even when we were foragers that women live for 20 years after menopause. And of course, that's also true for men. So men live for that extra 20 years as well. It's not quite as vivid an evolutionary paradox with men, but it's true in both cases. And that happened pretty quickly. So then there's this puzzle about why do we have that extra 20 years there. And one piece is that, and you know, that 20 years comes with decreased strength and speed and all the things that we know about as we as we get older. And one piece clearly is that those immature, intelligent children
关于这一点，有两件非常有趣的事情。首先，如我们所知，人类拥有漫长的、基本上是祖母期的阶段——大约20年的绝经后时期，这确实使我们与最近的灵长类亲戚区别开来，也使我们与大多数其他动物区别开来。而且这一直都是真的。即使在我们还是采集者的时候也是如此，女性在绝经后还能活20年。当然，这对男性来说也是如此。所以男性也能多活这20年。对于男性来说，这并不是一个那么鲜明的进化悖论，但在两种情况下都是如此。而且这种现象发生得相当快。因此这就成了一个谜：为什么我们会有那额外的20年？其中一个部分是，你知道，那20年伴随着力量和随着我们变老而熟知的各种体能下降。
need a lot more parental investment. They need a lot more taking care of than, say, primate babies do. And there's some very nice evidence in anthropology that it's those older people who are actually putting in the time and energy and investment to just help keep those children alive. But there's an even more interesting story. The one creature that we know of that also has post-metapausal grandmothers, aside from humans, are orcas. Killer whale. It might seem a bit surprising. Why orcas? Well, it turns out orcas are among the few other species that also has cultural traditions
而其中一部分显然是那些尚未成熟、聪明的孩子需要更多的父母投资。比起灵长类婴儿，他们需要更多的照顾。人类学中有非常好的证据表明，正是那些年长的人投入了大量的时间、精力来帮助这些孩子维持生命。但还有一个更有趣的故事。除了人类之外，我们所知的唯一也拥有绝经后祖母的生物是虎鲸。也就是逆戟鲸。这可能有点令人惊讶。为什么是虎鲸呢？
where a particular pod of orcas will choose a particular kind of food, you know, krill or or shrimp or other fish. And it turns out that it's actually the grandmothers who are leading the pod who are pointing to the sources of the food and seem to be responsible for some of this cultural transmission. Now, one of the things that I think has become increasingly clear about, human is that we depend on these cultural traditions, again, much more than any other species. Other species have these traditions, but it's, you know, it's sort of the secret of our success. It's one of the things that's most distinctive about us. If you think about all the differences
事实证明，虎鲸是少数几种也拥有文化传统的物种之一，特定的一群虎鲸会选择特定种类的食物，比如磷虾、小虾或其他鱼类。事实证明，实际上是领导鲸群的祖母们在指引食物的来源，并似乎负责了部分文化传播。现在，我认为关于人类越来越清晰的一点是，我们对这些文化传统的依赖，再次强调，比任何其他物种都要多得多。其他物种也有这些传统，但这可以说是我们成功的秘诀，也是我们最具特色的地方之一。如果你想想我们现在坐在这里用Zoom电脑所做的事情，
between what we're doing now as we sit here on our Zoom computers and what we were doing not so long ago in the Pleistocene, all of that's due to cumulative culture. And if you think about elders like grandmothers, one of the things that they can do is pass on information about what people have discovered in the past. So before writing the 150 years between my grandchildren and my grandparents, I can tell them stories about my own grandparents, that's about as far back as you could go. And there's some fascinating anthropological evidence that that's one of the main things that elders are doing.
与不久前我们在更新世所做的事情之间的所有差异，这一切都归功于累积文化。如果你想想祖母这样的长辈，他们能做的事情之一就是传递关于人们过去所发现的信息。所以在我的孙辈和我的祖父母之间相隔150年的时间里写下来之前，我可以给他们讲我自己的祖父母的故事，这差不多就是你能回溯的最远距离了。而且有一些迷人的人类学证据表明，这就是长辈们在做的主的事情之一。
So a lot of this work is in a special issue of the philosophical transactions of the Royal Society that I edited recently and there's a marvelous piece by Michael Gervyn who was looking at hunting. And what he points out, this will be familiar to everybody in COVID time, is that it's quite hard to actually do something well and teach someone else how to do it well. So when we make pancakes in my house in the wonderful pre-COVID days with my grandchildren, one of the discoveries that I made is when the grandchildren weren't there, it's so much faster to make the pancakes. It's like four times. Four times as fast. On Sunday mornings, I keep saying to my husband,
所以，很多这样的研究都收录在我最近编辑的英国皇家学会哲学汇刊特刊中，其中有一篇迈克尔·格文（Michael Gervyn）写的精彩文章，探讨了狩猎。他指出的一点（经历了新冠疫情的人都会感同身受）是，实际上要把一件事做好，并教别人也做好，是相当困难的。因此，在新冠疫情前的那些美好日子里，当我和孙辈们在我家做煎饼时，我发现的一个事实是，当孙辈们不在时，做煎饼的速度要快得多。简直快了四倍。快了整整四倍。在星期天的早晨，我总是对丈夫说，
how come this is going so quickly? And I think everyone who's had a children at home is aware of that. And what Gervin found was that the hunters sort of the prime of life, 35-year-old hunters were the ones who were most effective. But they weren't teaching as much as the elders were. So the elders weren't as good at actually doing the hunting anymore. They weren't as strong. But they were skilled.
为什么这进展得这么快？我想每一个家里有孩子的人都对此深有体会。格文发现，正值壮年的猎人，即35岁的猎人，才是最高效的。但他们并不像长辈那样热衷于教导。因此，长辈们实际上已经不太擅长打猎了。他们不再那么强壮。但他们经验丰富。
They were the ones who had the knowledge. So what happened was that those older hunters were going out with the kids and actually teaching them, showing them what was going on, helping them to figure out what was going on in the world. Now, my own personal, this is just a just a so story, but I think a kind of slightly comforting Joso story for us, oldsters, is you think about that function. Another thing that Gervin found was that the elders were the ones who were passing on the stories and the songs and the big structure of how. the world worked. And again, if you think about what you do as a grandmother, that's exactly what you do, right? Tell stories about when you were a kid and sing songs. And if you think about it from a cognitive perspective, again, I think something that's really important that we haven't emphasized enough in psychology is this idea of trade-offs that we can't have a system
他们是掌握知识的人。所以发生的情况是，那些年长的猎人会带着孩子们出去，实际教导他们，向他们展示发生了什么，帮助他们弄清楚世界上到底在发生什么。现在，我个人的经历，这只是一个微不足道的故事，但我认为对我们这些老年人来说，这是一个稍微有点安慰的小故事，你回想一下那个功能。格文发现的另一件事是，长辈们负责传递故事、歌曲以及世界如何运作宏大结构。同样，如果你回想一下你作为祖母所做的事情，这正是你所做的，对吧？讲讲你小时候的故事，唱唱歌。如果你从认知的角度来思考，同样，我认为心理学中有一个非常重要、我们尚未充分强调的观点，那就是权衡取舍的概念，即我们不可能拥有一个系统
that does everything perfectly, or even does everything well. There's always trade-offs between some things and others. So I think there might be a trade-off between being able to remember what happened yesterday, right? Which is not all that helpful if you're trying to teach a new generation. They know what happened yesterday. But remembering what happened, you know, 50 years ago, that might actually really be helpful. So that's slightly comforting when, for us, people who can't remember where we put our glasses yesterday, but are really, really good about telling stories about what happened
能把所有事都做到完美，甚至把所有事都做好。某些事情和另一些事情之间总是存在权衡取舍。所以我认为，记住昨天发生了什么可能存在一种权衡取舍，对吧？如果你正试图教导新一代，这其实并没有太大帮助。他们知道昨天发生了什么。但是记住50年前发生了什么，那可能真的非常有用。所以这对于我们这些记不清昨天把眼镜放哪儿了，但却非常擅长讲述我们还是小女孩时发生了什么故事的人来说，
when we were a little girl. Yeah, back in the day. So we humans also have a long adolescence. And research shows that when you look at things like risk-taking behaviors, that our brains don't fully mature until our mid-20s. I'm just wondering, are teen brains more like children's brains or adults' brains?
有点小小的安慰。是的，在过去的日子里。所以我们人类也有一个漫长的青春期。研究表明，当你观察诸如冒险行为之类的事情时，我们的大脑直到20岁中期才完全成熟。我只是在想，青少年的大脑更像儿童的大脑还是成年的大脑？
Yeah, this is a really fascinating piece. And in a piece that I did in Piano Acid in 2017, really for the first time in my career, I started looking at adolescents and thinking about adolescents. And what happened was one of the one of those nice empirical things where I wanted to, you know, this argument about the kids being more exploratory isn't just sort of made up out of whole cloth. We've done a whole bunch of studies that show that children are actually better at learning than adults in cases where the hypothesis
是的，这是一个非常引人入胜的课题。在我2017年为《永恒之光》撰写的一篇文章中，我职业生涯中第一次真正开始关注和思考青少年。当时的情况是那种很好的实证研究之一，我想证明，关于孩子更具探索精神的这种观点并非凭空捏造。我们做了一大堆研究表明，在假设不太寻常的情况下，或者在为了获得所需信息而必须冒险的情况下，儿童实际上比成年人更善于学习。
is sort of unusual or in cases where you have to sort of take a risk to be able to get the information that you need. And so we wanted to see how that unfolded over the lifespan. So we tested kids from people from five until up through adulthood. And what we discovered somewhat surprisingly was especially if it was a social task, a task about how you understand other people. The adolescence, what you saw is this really interesting curve where the preschoolers were very flexible. And then they became less flexible as they got to school age.
所以我们想看看这在整个生命周期中是如何展开的。因此，我们测试了从5岁到成年的人群。我们颇为惊讶地发现，特别是如果这是一个社交任务，一个关于你如何理解他人的任务。对于青少年，你所看到的是一个非常有趣的曲线，学龄前儿童非常灵活。然后随着他们到了学龄，灵活性降低了。
And adults were not flexible at all. But the adolescents actually had this new peak of flexibility. And that fits with a lot of the neuroscience. suggest that especially in domains that have to do with the social world, you see this kind of reintroduction of plasticity and risk taking in adolescence. And if you think about it just even intuitively, any of you who've raised a child, right, you know, they're these crazy, difficult, imaginative preschoolers. And then they turn into, like, I am convinced that a nine-year-old is like the sanest person on the face of the universe, right? Like nine-year-old is my, my oldest,
成年人则一点也不灵活。但青少年实际上迎来了灵活性新的峰值。这与许多神经科学的研究相吻合。这些研究表明，特别是在与社交世界相关的领域，你在青春期会看到这种弹性和冒险精神的再度出现。如果你从直觉上来思考，任何抚养过孩子的人都知道，对吧，他们是那些疯狂、难缠、富有想象力的学龄前儿童。然后他们变成了——我深信九岁的孩子是世界上最理智的人，对吧？比如九岁的孩子，我的大孙子，
a grandson is nine now. And it's just, you know, he's calm, he's sane, he's rational, he's thoughtful. And then they hit adolescence and suddenly, wait a minute, it's like they're three again. They're doing all these things because you told them not to and they're crazy and they're taking risks. And I think there's actually some evidence to suggest that adolescence is like this secondary period of exploration, especially about things like how the social world works, how the social world should be organized. And a lot of the risk-taking that we see both in preschoolers and in adolescence is connected to this explorer exploit tradeoff about trying to get more information
现在九岁了。他很平静，很理智，很理性，很体贴。然后他们进入青春期，突然间，等一下，他们就像三岁小孩一样了。他们做所有这些事情，只是因为你告诉他们不要做，而且他们很疯狂，还在冒险。我认为实际上有一些证据表明，青春期就像是探索的第二个时期，特别是关于社交世界如何运作、社交世界应该如何组织之类的事情。我们在学龄前儿童和青少年身上看到的许多冒险行为，都与这种试图获取更多信息的“探索-利用”权衡有关，
versus taking risks than having costs. You've talked about how your experiences as a sister and as a mother influenced your research and your career path. Can you just tell our listeners a little bit about your own history and how you became interested in studying children because that wasn't considered a serious field of study at the time when you began, right? Well, you know, it's interesting because I actually began my career as a philosopher and I'm still an affiliate in philosophy and I still think that's kind of what my real vocation
而不仅是承担成本和风险。您曾谈到您作为姐姐和母亲的经历如何影响了您的研究和职业生涯。您能给我们的听众简单讲讲您自己的经历，以及您是如何对研究儿童产生兴趣的吗？因为在您刚开始的时候，这并不被认为是一个严肃的研究领域，对吧？嗯，你知道，这很有趣，因为我最初的职业其实是哲学家，我现在仍然是哲学系的附属研究员，我仍然认为这有点像我真正的职业。
is. That's the thing that I'm best at. And I was interested as a philosopher in some of these big questions about how the world works. And the deepest question, the one that I was and continue to be really the most interested, the one that's really really propelled my entire career. Part of the reason why I'm interested in AI now, for example, is how is it that we could ever know about the world around us? So, you know, all that gets to us from the world are a bunch of photons hitting the back of our eyes and disturbances of air at our ears. And yet we know about a world that's full of objects and people
这是我最擅长的事情。作为一名哲学家，我对世界如何运作的一些宏大问题很感兴趣。最深奥的问题，也是我过去、现在都最感兴趣的问题，真正推动了我整个职业生涯的问题。这也是为什么我现在对人工智能感兴趣的部分原因，比如：我们怎么可能了解我们周围的世界？所以，你知道，从世界传递给我们的所有信息，只是一束撞击我们眼底的光子和耳边的空气扰动。然而我们却了解一个充满物体、人和
and thoughts and eventually, you know, quarks and distant planets. And it always seemed kind of remarkable to me. That's a deep philosophical question going all the way back to Plato and Aristotle. How does that work? How is that possible? But I was also the oldest of six children, which means that I was sort of a caregiver. And I had my first child when I was 23. So really, my whole life with very few exceptions. I've been, I've been, and thank God for grandchildren.
思想的世界，最终还有夸克和遥远的行星。这在我看来总是非常了不起。这是一个可以追溯到柏拉图和亚里士多德的深奥哲学问题。这是如何运作的？这怎么可能？但我也是六个孩子中的老大，这意味着我某种程度上是一个照顾者。我在23岁时有了第一个孩子。所以实际上我的一生中，极少数例外除外，我都一直——感谢上帝赐予孙辈，
I've been engaged and involved with children. And it always seemed to me that children were the sensible people to look at if you wanted to ask that big question. Because they're the ones who are actually doing all of that learning. They're the ones who are figuring out how the world works. And that wasn't unique. Pige, the great founder of Covenous Development thought that. In fact, Socrates thought that looking at children was a way that you could answer those questions. But it was still, you know, for obvious reasons, children are, were,
我一直与孩子们打交道，并参与其中。在我看来，如果你想探究那个宏大的问题，儿童一直都是最明智的研究对象。因为他们才是真正进行所有这些学习的人。他们是弄清楚世界如何运作的人。这并不是独一无二的。认知发展的伟大奠基人皮亚杰就是这么认为的。事实上，苏格拉底也认为观察儿童是回答这些问题的一种途径。但它仍然——出于显而易见的原因，儿童曾经是，
and are, you know, stuff that kids, moms take care of. It's women's work. It's domestic. It doesn't quite have the kind of status and seriousness often that other, that other, other kinds of research have. So my sort of, I mean, literally from the time I was just starting out my career very intentionally, I set out, I had a sort of choice point of, should I just go and become a philosopher and be,
现在也是，你知道的，那是妈妈们照顾的东西。这是女性的工作。它是家庭琐事。它往往不像其他类型的研究那样，具有那种地位和严肃性。所以我的某种程度上——我是说， literalmente 从我职业生涯刚开始的时候，我就非常刻意地出发，我面临着一个抉择点：我是应该去当一个哲学家，去做
and be a woman who's doing the kinds of things that analytic philosophers talk about, or should I embrace this very female enterprise of looking at children and just make people realize that looking at children was just as deep, just as interesting, just as significant as looking at brains or looking at computers or doing reaction times or any of the other kinds of things
分析哲学家们谈论的那种事情，还是应该拥抱这种非常女性化的观察儿童的事业，并让人们意识到，观察儿童与研究大脑、研究计算机、测量反应时间或成年人所做的其他任何事情一样深奥、有趣且意义重大？
that adults do? I'm not sure I've completely succeeded at that, But that's sort of the mission. And I hope that my students are carrying on that mission. Has the fact that more women are entering research psychology contributed to the changes that you've seen in your field? Yeah, I think there's no doubt about that. So both the fact that more women are involved and the fact that more men are involved with children, right? So one of the puzzles, for instance, you know, the really big revolution,
我不确定我是否完全成功了，但这就是我的使命。我希望我的学生们能够继承这一使命。更多女性进入心理学研究领域这一事实，是否促进了你所看到的你所在领域的变化？是的，毫无疑问。既有更多女性参与的事实，也有更多男性参与照顾儿童的事实，对吧？所以，举个例子，其中一个谜题——真正巨大的革命，
has been our understanding of babies and young children. So even when I started out, which is a while ago, but not that long ago, I remember people telling me when I was at Oxford that babies were decorticate, that they were like, you know, kind of like vegetables, that they didn't have a cortex, they couldn't really think. And even Phaje, you know, the great founder of cognitive development, thought that babies were babies and young children, up until about five, were irrational and egocentric and solipsistic.
一直是我们对婴儿和幼儿的理解。因此，甚至在我刚开始的时候——那是有一段时间了，但也没有那么久——我记得我在牛津时，有人告诉我婴儿没有大脑皮层，他们就像，你知道，有点像植物，他们没有皮层，他们真的不会思考。甚至皮亚杰，认知发展的伟大奠基人，也认为婴儿和五岁以下的幼儿是不理性的、以自我为中心的、唯我论的。
And we've just totally turned that on its head. That views just 180 degrees different. So now we think that even the youngest babies both know more and learn more than we ever would have thought. But an interesting kind of puzzle, it's like, why were they so wrong for so long, right? I mean, what was it? How could all of these people,
而我们彻底颠覆了这种看法。这种观点发生了180度的转变。所以现在我们认为，即使是最年幼的婴儿，他们所知道的和所学到的也远超我们的想象。但一个有趣的谜题是，为什么他们会错得那么离谱，持续了那么久？我是说，这到底是怎么回事？所有人，
the smartest people, the philosophers, the psychologists, like psychiatrists, how could they've gotten it so wrong? Well, if they weren't, if they weren't the caregivers, is they weren't having the same interaction every day with babies, right? I mean, would that be part of it? Exactly. And I think part of the reason was that the people who were actually spending time with babies did think, wait a minute, I think he recognized me.
最聪明的人、哲学家、心理学家、精神病学家，怎么会错得这么离谱？好吧，如果他们不是照顾者，如果他们没有每天与婴儿进行同样的互动，对吧？我的意思是，这也是原因的一部分吗？完全是这样。我认为部分原因在于，那些真正花时间陪婴儿的人确实认为：等一下，我觉得他认出我了。
I think he understands this. They had a rich sense of it, but of course they weren't the people who were writing the books. And it's really striking to me now. I have this wonderful new four-month-old grandson, who very sadly is often in Montreal. But my granddaughter and grandson literally every morning send me a video of what the baby's doing. And I've realized, of course, that technology means that I get to see how he's imitating or he's looking or he's engaged. But of course, those are just a few moments during the day. A lot of the time during the day, a baby will be asleep or a baby will be fussy or a baby won't be doing those things that really demonstrate.
我想他听懂了。他们有一种丰富的直觉，但他们当然不是写书的人。这现在让我感到非常震撼。我有一个可爱的四个月大的新孙子，很遗憾，他经常在蒙特利尔。但我的孙女和孙子几乎每天早上都会给我发一段视频，展示宝宝在做什么。我当然意识到，科技意味着我能看到他是如何模仿、观察或参与其中的。但当然，这些只是白天里的短短几个时刻。在白天的很多时间里，婴儿都在睡觉、哭闹，或者不做那些真正能展现的事情。
demonstrate how smart they are. And it's kind of, if you didn't actually, you know, have the video phone sitting right there so that you could pick it up and do a video at the very moment when the baby's doing it, it would just seem like it was lost. And, and in fact, you know, again, if I think about it when we were starting out, you know, you wanted to record a baby, you had to take a big, heavy, you know, big heavy reel-to-reel recorder and a box full of equipment and hope that you could get something. And I'm wondering if, you know, the new technology means that we'll start getting more data and appreciating more just exactly what babies can do. Let's talk for a minute about your book The Gardener and the Carpenter.
展现他们有多聪明。而且，如果你没有把视频电话就放在手边，以便在宝宝做这件事的那个确切时刻拿起来录一段视频，这一切似乎就会错失。事实上，你知道，再次回想一下，当我们刚开始的时候，如果你想录下婴儿的影像，你得搬出一个又大又重的盘式录音机和一箱设备，祈祷能录下点什么。我在想，你知道，新技术是否意味着我们将开始获得更多的数据，并更加赞赏婴儿到底能做些什么。我们花几分钟来谈谈你的书《园丁与木匠》。
You talk about current parenting culture doesn't really mesh with what science is telling us about the purpose of childhood. Can you explain the difference between a gardener and a carpenter when it comes to parenting and what insights parents and other caregivers should be getting from this work? of yours. Yeah. So I think the model, it's interesting that the very word parenting really only started showing up in the 1970s in the United States. Of course, we've had mothers and fathers and parents forever. But the idea that parenting is this occupation, this thing that you do, is relatively recent. And I think the other thing that's relatively recent is a generation of people raising children who hadn't actually really, you know, been the way I was, the oldest of six
你谈到当前的育儿文化实际上与科学告诉我们的童年目的并不吻合。你能解释一下育儿方面园丁和木匠的区别，以及父母和其他照顾者应该从你的这项工作中获得什么启示吗？是的。所以我觉得这种模式很有趣，事实上“育儿”（parenting）这个词直到20世纪70年代才在美国出现。当然，我们自古以来就有母亲、父亲和父母。但认为育儿是一种职业、一种你必须要做的事情的这种想法是相对较新的。而且我认为另一件相对较新的事情是，有一代人抚养孩子时，并没有真正经历过——像我一样，作为六个孩子中的老大——
children haven't had much experience of raising children before, but had lots of experience of going to school and working. So they tended to think about raising children as being like going to school and working. It's something that you have a bunch of techniques for. If you just get the right technique and you focus enough, you'll be able to bring about the right outcome. It's not quite clear what the right outcome is, but you know, something like you'll have the child who goes to Harvard, right? And that that picture is very, very much not like the picture that comes from thinking about evolution and development. It's almost the opposite of this explorer exploit tradeoff picture that I've been talking about. That picture is a picture where the whole point is to provide children with
在此之前没有太多抚养孩子的经验，但有大量上学和工作的经验。因此，他们往往把抚养孩子想象得就像上学和工作一样。这是一件有一套技巧的事情。如果你掌握了正确的技巧，并且足够专心，你就能够产生正确的结果。虽然不太清楚正确的结果是什么，但你知道，类似于你会培养出一个上哈佛的孩子，对吧？这种画面与从进化和发展的角度思考所产生的画面大相径庭。它几乎与我一直在谈论的“探索-利用”权衡画面截然相反。那种画面是这样一个画面：其全部意义在于为儿童提供
a rich, safe environment in which the children can come out in a wide variety of different ways in which things are very variable and unpredictable. A metaphor I've used to try and describe that is if you think about a carpenter who actually goes out and has a picture in their head about here's the chair that I want to build and here's the wood and here's what I'm going to do. And if I'm very precise and careful, I can make exactly the kind of chair that I want versus a gardener where you have no idea what's going to happen in your garden, or at least from most messy cottage gardeners like me. But also more deeply, one of the things that we've discovered from ecology is that for a garden or any other ecological system to be successful, the key is for it to be variable,
一个丰富、安全的环境，在这个环境中，孩子们可以以各种各样不同的方式成长，其中的事物充满变数且无法预测。我用来描述这种比喻的是，如果你想想一个木匠，他实际上走出门去，脑子里有一个画面：这就是我要做的椅子，这就是木头，这就是我要做的事情。如果我足够精确和仔细，我就能做出我想要的椅子；而园丁则不同，你根本不知道你的花园里会发生什么，至少对我这种大多数杂乱的村舍园丁来说是这样。但更深层次的是，我们从生态学中发现的一个道理是，为了让花园或任何其他生态系统取得成功，关键在于它必须充满变数，
for it to be able to do different things in different circumstances, for it to be resilient, so that when we have a drought the way we have in California, the succulents are going to do really well and the British cottage garden flowers are not going to do as well, but it'll reverse when the range come. So having a lot of variability, a lot of difference is, one of the things that make systems resilient. And the point about childhood is to bring about that kind of unexpected variability in the light of change.
为了让它能够在不同情况下做不同的事情，为了让它具有弹性，当发生像加州那样的旱灾时，多肉植物会长得很好，而英国乡村花园的花则长得没那么好，但当雨季来临时代情况就会逆转。因此，拥有大量的变异性和差异性是使系统具有弹性的原因之一。而童年的意义就在于，在面对变化时，带来那种意想不到的变异性。
So it's just the opposite of what the kind of Carpenter parenting picture would suggest. Well, I want to talk for a minute about some of the newer technologies and their role in parenting. And it's not at all uncommon to see parents in malls or restaurants handing toddlers or even babies mobile phones or iPads to distract them or keep them busy. Is that kind of parenting gardening or
所以这与那种木匠式的育儿观念所暗示的恰恰相反。好吧，我想花点时间谈谈一些新技术及其在育儿中的作用。在商场或餐馆里，看到父母把手机或iPad交给蹒跚学步的幼儿甚至婴儿来分散他们的注意力或让他们保持安静，这并不是什么罕见的事。这种育儿方式是园丁式的，还是
carpentering? Can you tell? Well, I think it's important to say that one of the functions of this kind of garden has always been that each generation is dealing with a different universe, a different environment. It's different from the one before. That's one of the things, go back to the grandparents, that's that's one of the things about our ability to have culture is that not only do we pass on culture from before but we also innovate so we also get new cultural discovery and part of what childhood has always been about adolescents particularly I think but childhood as well is all right I'm in a slightly different environment than I was than my parents are how do I cope with that environment and of course that's very vivid if you're thinking about if you're thinking about technology now so I think, again, COVID has made it really striking.
木匠式的？你能分得清吗？嗯，我认为很重要的一点是要说明，这种花园的功能之一一直是每一代人都在应对一个不同的宇宙，一个不同的环境。它与前一代人不同。回到祖父母那一辈，这就是我们拥有文化能力的一个特征，不仅是我们把过去的文化传下去，而且我们还会创新，从而获得新的文化发现。童年的部分意义——尤其是青春期，我认为童年也是如此——在于：好吧，我处在一个与我父母略有不同的环境中，我该如何应对这个环境？当然，如果你考虑到现在的技术，这一点非常生动，所以我认为，同样，新冠疫情让这一点变得非常引人注目。
I think all of us have had this experience of the children around us being much better at dealing with Zoom than we are. It's almost a cliche about how quickly children are adapting to this new world compared to adults. But of course, what culture is all about, and that's where the grandmothers come in, is that we always have this, and this again is this point about tradeoffs, We have the way we can do that is because we are passing on the values that we think are important to us, the values that we've discovered, the things that we've found out about the world. We can pass those on to children and then they're equipped with those values to deal with the new world, which is different from the world that we grew up in. And I think technology is a good example of that. So, you know, I can feel myself, look, standing in front of a screen all day is not is not a great happy way to be. and, you know, having the experience of going off into a corner and reading a book or going on into the
我想我们所有人都有这样的体验：身边的孩子比我们更擅长应对Zoom。关于孩子们比成年人更快适应这个新世界，这几乎成了一个陈词滥调。但当然，文化的全部意义就在于——这也是祖母们发挥作用的地方——我们一直都有这种权衡，我们之所以能做到这一点，是因为我们正在传递我们认为对我们很重要的价值观，我们所发现的价值观，以及我们对世界的了解。我们可以把这些传给孩子们，然后他们就拥有了这些价值观来应对新世界，这个世界与我们成长的世界不同。我认为技术就是一个很好的例子。所以，你知道，我能感觉到，听吧，一整天站在屏幕前并不是一种快乐健康的生活方式。而且，你知道，去角落里读本书或者去
garden and playing, those are all really good experiences. And I think I can pass that on to my grandchildren at the same time that my grandchildren can figure out, well, how do you, the puzzle that we all have, how do you integrate that with the reality of the new technology? But no matter what, I think they'll never learn penmanship again, right? I mean, you can't impart that particular knowledge. Well, I have to say as a child who was, if I do say so myself, was always extremely good at school, did very well in everything growing up except damn penmanship. I am as a slightly, slightly disgracing person who can't draw and can't write, I'm willing to give that up. So we've touched a little bit on artificial intelligence. I know that's an area where you become pretty deeply involved in the research and just wondering,
花园里玩耍，这些都是非常好的体验。我想我可以把这些传递给我的孙辈，同时我的孙辈也能弄清楚——我们所有人面临的谜题——你如何将它与新技术的新现实结合起来？但无论如何，我认为他们再也不会学习书法了，对吧？我的意思是，你无法传授那种特定的知识。好吧，我必须说，作为一个小时候（如果我敢这么说的话）在学校总是表现极好、除了该死的书法外其他什么都做得很好的孩子，作为一个稍微有点不会画画和不会写字的尴尬的人，我愿意放弃那个。所以我们稍微触及了一下人工智能。我知道这是你深入参与研究的一个领域，我只是在想，
what can AI researchers learn from developmental psychologists and how would AI based on children's learning be different from the way that many AI systems are being built right now? Yeah. So, you know, we were talking before about the effect of having women in the profession and how it changes the kinds of things that we think about. And I think we've had a really nice dramatic example of that recently with AI where AI's been very heavily dominated by men and the kind of models of AI learning have been obviously dominated by the people who are doing it. But people in AI, you know, for good diversity reasons as well as for intellectual reasons, have started to pay more and more attention to children. And of course, a lot of the people
AI研究人员可以从发展心理学家那里学到什么？基于儿童学习的AI与现在许多AI系统的构建方式有什么不同？是的。所以，你知道，我们之前讨论过女性在职进行业中的影响，以及它如何改变我们思考问题的方式。我认为最近我们在人工智能方面看到了一个非常精彩、戏剧性的例子，人工智能在很大程度上由男性主导，人工智能学习的模型显然由从事这项工作的人主导。但人工智能领域的人，出于良好的多元化原因以及出于智力原因，已经开始越来越多地关注儿童。当然，许多
who study children are women. So they've been listening to what women have to say about how children learn. And again, the wonderful thing about AI is these, they're in. engineers and engineers are great about just being willing to take everything, anything into account that will make their machines work better, no matter what its other characteristics are. And if you think about AI, I think there's been real interest in children in particular, quite recently in the past, in the past few years, because the big advances in AI have been advances in machine learning, in learning. So the big, the big, the big, uh, the big discoveries have been that we do better if we actually try to have machines that can learn from the world rather than trying to program in what they should know in the first place. But the kinds of learning that these machines do are pretty limited. So they're, you know, something like here's a giant data set of images and I'm going to tell you label these are cats and these are dogs
研究儿童的人都是女性。所以他们一直在倾听女性对儿童如何学习的看法。同样，人工智能奇妙的地方在于，他们是工程师，而工程师非常乐意将任何能让他们的机器工作得更好的因素考虑进去，无论它具有什么其他特征。如果你考虑人工智能，我认为最近几年人们对儿童产生了真正的兴趣，因为人工智能的重大进展是机器学习和学习方面的进展。所以最大的发现是，如果我们实际上努力让机器能够从世界中学习，而不是试图一开始就将它们应该知道的东西编程进去，我们会做得更好。但这些机器所进行的学习是非常有限的。所以，它们，你知道，类似于这里有一个巨大的图像数据集，我要告诉你，这些贴上标签的是猫，这些是狗，
and now your job is to say which ones are cats and which ones are dogs. And it's amazing that or you know here's a game of go. and now your job is play a million games ago and then figure out which times what you have to do to win versus lose. And it's amazing that the systems can do as much as they can that way. But the result is that they tend to be quite narrow. So they're good at doing the things that you've trained them to do, but they're not very good at generalizing to new examples. So you give them a slightly unusual picture of a dog, let's say a video of a dog instead of a picture,
现在你的工作是说哪些是猫，哪些是狗。令人惊奇的是，或者你知道，这里有一局围棋，现在你的工作是下一百万盘围棋，然后弄清楚在什么情况下你必须做什么才能赢，什么情况下会输。系统能够以这种方式做到这一点，真是令人惊奇。但结果是，它们往往相当狭隘。所以它们擅长做你训练它们做的事情，但它们很不擅长推广到新的例子。你给它们一张稍微不寻常的狗的照片，比方说是一段狗的视频而不是照片，
and they completely bomb out. You change the rules of the game a little bit and they can't use the things that they learned before. And that makes them very different from children who can have just one or two examples of something that's new and make a really wonderful, unexpected generalization. An example I give a lot, again, from my grandson is when he was about four, his grandfather said,
它们就会彻底搞砸。你稍微改变一下游戏规则，它们就无法使用之前学过的内容。这使得它们与儿童大不相同，儿童只需一两个关于新事物的例子，就能做出非常精彩、意想不到的推广。我经常举的一个例子，依然来自我的孙子，当他四岁左右时，他的祖父说，
Gee, I wish I could be a kid again. And Augie said, why don't you try don't eat any broccoli and don't eat any green beans and don't eat any healthy food? And then maybe you could be a kid again. Now, that's a wonderful, you know, that's my brilliant grandson. But any four-year-olds will give you examples like this where it's not like anyone had told him that. But of course, you can see the rationale behind it, right? If eating vegetables turns you from a kid into a big strong grown-up, then you should be able to reverse the process.
天哪，我希望我能再当一次小孩。奥吉说，你为什么不试着不吃任何西蓝花，不吃任何青豆，也不吃任何健康食品？然后也许你就能再当一次小孩了。现在，这是一个美妙的，你知道，这是我聪明的孙子。但任何四岁的孩子都会给你提供这样的例子，这并不是说有人告诉过他这些。但当然，你能看出背后的逻辑，对吧？如果吃蔬菜能把一个小孩子变成一个又大又强壮的成年人，那么你应该能够逆转这个过程。
And that's an example of something where without any explicit supervision, without anybody telling you what the answer is, you think of something that's a really good generalization, a really good creative new idea. And that's one of the things that three and four-year-olds are fantastic at doing. That's part of why it's so much fun to just listen to them talk. So that's one thing that the children can do. So how is it that they do it? And we think that there's, so I've been part of a big project that DARPA, the defense research group that actually helped invent the internet and modern computers, DARPA is funding to try and see if we could design an artificial system that was as smart as an 18-month-old, say. And the things that we think are really crucial that makes the children different from current AI is that they build models of the world. They're not just looking at statistics.
这是一个例子：在没有任何明确监督的情况下，在没有人告诉你答案的情况下，你想到了一个非常好的推广、一个非常好的有创意的全新想法。三四岁的孩子非常擅长做这件事，这就是为什么听他们说话那么有趣的原因之一。这是孩子们能做的一件事。那么，他们是怎么做到的呢？我们认为，我一直参与由国防部高级研究计划局（DARPA，曾帮助发明互联网和现代计算机的国防研究机构）资助的一个大型项目，该项目旨在研究我们是否能设计出一个像18个月大的婴儿那样聪明的系统。我们认为对使儿童不同于当前AI至关重要的真正核心在于，他们构建了世界的模型。他们不仅仅是在看统计数据。
They're actually thinking of things like, okay, how does eating turn you into a grown-up? Importantly, they explore. So instead of being sort of stuck in their mainframes, you know, we children are out there doing experiments all the time. When they do it, we call it getting into everything. But they're getting into everything. They're going out and actually getting information. And a lot of, if there's a lot of exciting work now in AI, trying to make curious, That's part of what we've been doing at Berkeley.
他们实际上在思考诸如：好吧，吃东西是如何把你变成一个成年人的？重要的是，他们会探索。因此，孩子们不是被困在大型机里，而是随时随地都在做实验。当他们这样做时，我们称之为“到处捣乱”。但他们确实在到处捣乱。他们走出去，真正获取信息。现在人工智能领域有很多令人兴奋的工作，试图创造好奇心。这就是我们在伯克利一直在做的事情的一部分。
Could we make AIs that are curious the way that children are? And it looks at that makes them much smarter than when they're not curious. And then a third thing is that this cultural piece that we learn from other people. So children are imitating, you know, literally from the time they're born. And they imitate in very smart, sophisticated ways. It isn't just kind of mindless copying.
我们能否制造出像孩子一样好奇的AI？看起来这让他们比不好奇时聪明得多。第三点是我们从其他人那里学到的文化部分。所以孩子们在模仿，你知道，从他们出生起就在字面意义上模仿。而且他们以非常聪明、复杂的方式模仿。这不仅仅是一种盲目的复制。
They're thinking a lot about what is it that the other person around me is trying to teach me? The work that I did in the first part of my career back in the 80s, was what came to be called theory of mind. How do we understand what's going on in the minds of other people? Again, when we started in the 80s, there wasn't even a word for this. Nobody quite thought of it as being something that would be interesting to find out about. Now it's kind of an industry.
他们在深入思考我身边的另一个人试图教给我什么？我在职业生涯早期（即80年代）所做的工作，后来被称为“心智理论”。我们如何理解他人脑海中正在发生的事情？同样，当我们在80年代开始时，甚至还没有一个词来形容这个。没有人认为这会是一件有趣的事情。现在它几乎成了一个行业。
And one of the things that, again, people in AI have realized is if you want an AI that works like a person, it needs to understand people. It needs to have a theory of mind. And it needs to use that to try to learn from other people. So can you have a robot that could see someone do something? And it's sort of fascinating. been a wonderful learning experience for me. If you talk to people in robotics, for instance,
人工智能领域的人意识到的一点是：如果你想要一个像人一样工作的人工智能，它就需要了解人。它需要具备心智理论。并且它需要利用这一点来试图向其他人学习。那么，你能拥有一个能看到别人做某事的机器人吗？这有点着迷。对我来说，这是一次绝妙的学习经历。如果你和机器人领域的人交谈，举个例子，
and you think, OK, well, this should be easy, right? You'll just show the robot that someone's reaching for something and it'll imitate. But it turns out what the robot will do is imitate exactly the absolute trajectory of what the person does. And then if you just move the object over an inch, it'll fail because it doesn't know what it's supposed to do. Whereas the kids will, you know, figure out,
你会想，好吧，这应该很简单，对吧？你只需向机器人展示某人正在伸手拿某物，它就会模仿。但事实证明，机器人会做的是完全模仿人类动作的绝对轨迹。然后，如果你把物体移动一英寸，它就会失败，因为它不知道它应该做什么。而孩子们会，你知道，弄清楚，
what is it that you want me to do? Is that the right kind of thing to do? What would be a better way of doing it? They're doing this in a much more sophisticated way. So that's another big piece, especially in robotics that people are trying to do based on what the kids are doing. So we both are finding out more about how kids brains and minds work by trying to say, what program are they using that would enable them to learn so much? That's been the big question that I've been asking all along.
你到底想让我做什么？那是正确的事情吗？有什么更好的方法来做这件事吗？他们正在以一种更加复杂的方式这样做。所以这是另一个重要的部分，特别是在机器人技术中，人们正试图根据孩子们的做法来做。因此，我们双方都在通过试图搞清楚“他们使用的是什么程序，能够让他们学习这么多？”来更多地了解儿童的大脑和心智是如何工作的。这一直是我一直在问的重大问题。但这
But that also means that we might be able to actually design some. systems that are better at learning. And then the last thing, which is the most recent thing that I've been working on that I've been most involved in over this last year, is part of the reason also why children can learn so much is because they have these caring adults around them who are taking care of them and also giving them the kind of information they need to be able to learn. And I'm getting more and more interested, again, maybe this is partly being a grandmother, what is involved, in being that kind of a caring adult. And it turns out that that's actually very important, oddly enough, in AI,
也意味着我们实际上可能能够设计出一些在学习方面更好的系统。最后一点，也是我最近一直在做的事情，是我在过去一年里最投入的事情，孩子们之所以能学到这么多，部分原因也是因为他们身边有这些照顾他们的成年人，他们在照顾他们的同时，也为他们提供了能够学习所需的信息。我越来越感兴趣，也许这部分是因为当了祖母，成为那种照顾人的成年人涉及到什么。事实奇怪的是，这在人工智能中实际上非常重要，
because one of the big problems in AI, it's called the alignment problem, is how could we get AIs that have the same values that we do? So, you know, the big fear about the AIs are going to kill us, which is probably not going to happen, but there's still a question about how do you tell an AI this is what you're trying to do? And it turns out, you know, with humans, it's very hard to actually articulate what is important? What's the value that what's the value that we're trying for? You know, the famous example is like you tell an AI to make paper clips. Does it turn everything in the world into a paperclip?
因为人工智能中的一个重大问题被称为“对齐问题”，即我们如何才能获得与我们具有相同价值观的人工智能？所以，你知道，对人工智能会杀死我们的巨大恐惧，这可能不会发生，但仍然存在一个问题：你如何告诉人工智能这是你试图做的事情？事实证明，你知道，对于人类来说，很难清晰地表达什么才是重要的？我们追求的价值观是什么？你知道，著名的例子就像你告诉人工智能去制作回形针。它会不会把世界上的所有东西都变成回形针？
It's people in AI call it the paperclip apocalypse, right? Does everything turn into a paperclip? Because you haven't told it. No, no, no, no. These things turn into paper clips. And actually, if you think about parenting or being a parent, we face that problem all the time, right? So we want our children to be able to be able to, to develop new values, develop new goals that aren't the same as ours, but that are good, that are important, that are not beneficent rather than, rather than negative. So this kind of cultural trade-off of, you know, tradition, grandma, I'm telling you the values that she had 100 years ago, and then you having to take them and adapt them to a world of Zoom screens, that's actually a problem that we have with AI as well, if we're going to actually have have genuinely intelligent AI, we're going to have to figure out some way that we can pass on,
人工智能界的人称之为回形针末日，对吧？一切都会变成回形针吗？因为你没有告诉它。不，不，不，不。这些东西会变成回形针。实际上，如果你想想育儿或为人父母，我们一直都在面对这个问题，对吧？所以我们希望我们的孩子能够培养出新的价值观，培养出与我们不同但却是好的、重要的、仁慈的而不是消极的新目标。因此，这种传统、奶奶（我告诉你她100年前拥有的价值观）的文化权衡，然后你必须接受它们并将它们适应Zoom屏幕的世界，如果我们真的想要拥有真正智能的人工智能，这也是我们在人工智能方面面临的问题，我们将不得不找出某种方法来传递，
here's what our values and goals are, here's what's important, here's what's good, and also enable the AI to be able to generalize, to discover and think of goals in a new way. And I think that's one of the main problems in AI ethics is how can we, if we want systems that are, in one hand, we want them to be autonomous. We don't want to be sitting there and telling them every single thing that they can do, but we want them to be good and we want them to do the things that we think are important. And actually, that's exactly the problem that every generation of caregivers faces. And the more I've thought about it, again, I think COVID has made it very vivid that caregiving is something that is absolutely crucial and central to human cognition and
我们的价值观和目标是什么，什么才是重要的，什么才是好的，同时也使人工智能能够进行推广，以崭新的方式去发现和思考目标。我认为这是人工智能伦理学中的主要问题之一：如果我们希望系统一方面具有自主性，我们不想坐在那里告诉它们可以做的每一件事，但我们希望它们是善良的，我们希望它们做我们认为重要的事情。实际上，这正是每一代看护者面临的问题。我越是思考这个问题，再次认为，新冠疫情让照顾人这件事变得非常生动，它是绝对至关重要的，是人类认知和进步以及人类生活的核心。
progress and human life. And yet again, as with children in general, It's very neglected. No one's thought about it very much. The moral philosophers don't think about it. It doesn't fit the kind of models that we typically have in our politics. And yet, you know, that individual elder care worker who cares about that person who's sick and is willing to, you know, risk their own health and take care of them, even though they're paid nothing and they're treated incredibly, incredibly badly. I think there's something so deep about humankind there, that we haven't thought about very much. We haven't understood in psychological or cognitive terms. Or again, watching this grandchild, this new grandchild. And within three weeks, he was actually early. He was premature. And yet here's this tiny little creature
然而，与一般儿童一样，它被严重忽视了。没有人对此进行过太多思考。道德哲学家不考虑它。它不符合我们政治中通常拥有的那种模式。然而，你知道，那个照顾生病之人的个别老年护理人员，愿意冒着自己健康的风险去照顾他们，尽管他们一无所获，而且被极其恶劣地对待。我认为这里面有人类如此深厚的东西，我们还没有深入思考。我们还没有用心理学或认知术语去理解它。或者再次看着这个孙子，这个新孙子。在三周内，他其实是个早产儿。然而，这里有这么一个小小的生物，
and here's these grownups who just care more about him than anything else in the world. That's an amazing human capacity that we haven't thought about very much we don't understand very well. So that's kind of the thing that's kind of on the cutting edge of what I've been doing with my time over the last year. Well, maybe, and this is kind of a last question, but I think that you perhaps have answered it in many ways in just this last topic that we were discussing. But do you think that
这里有这些成年人，他们对他的关心超过了世界上任何其他事情。这是人类的一种惊人的能力，我们还没有过多地思考，也没有很好地理解。所以这就是我过去一年花时间研究的前沿领域。好吧，也许（这是一个最后一个问题），但我认为你在我们刚才讨论的最后一个话题中，已经在很多方面回答了它。你认为在研究了儿童的心智这么多年之后，
there's still anything that could surprise you about children's minds after all these years of studying them? Yeah, well, of course, in detail, this is really true. Every time, we do with experiment in the lab, we get surprised. So it's, it's a, you know, I'm used to the fact that we'll do a pilot and I'll say, yeah, I'm positive the four-year-olds are going to be able to do this. I've got, you know, 40 years of experience, I know, and they do something completely, they do something completely unlike, completely unlike what I would have thought. Or vice versa, my student says, how about we try this? We, we had an experiment recently trying to see if children could understand this, some very abstract ideas from AI about variable choice where I'd say,
是否仍然有什么事情能让你感到惊讶？是的，当然，在细节上确实如此。每一次，我们在实验室做实验，我们都会感到惊讶。所以，你知道，我已经习惯了我们会做一个试点，然后我会说，是的，我确信四岁的孩子能够做到这一点。我有40年的经验，我知道，但他们做了一些完全不同的事情，完全出乎我的意料。或者反过来，我的学生说，我们尝试这个怎么样？我们最近做了一个实验，想看看孩子们是否能理解来自人工智能关于变量选择的一些非常抽象的想法，我会说，
no, that come on, that's something that they couldn't possibly understand. And they're, you know, like the two-year-olds are doing it in minutes. So I think, I think, I think there's no question that they're going to continue to do things that are, that are really surprising that I wouldn't have anticipated, but I wouldn't have anticipated in the first place, which of course is part of why it's so much more fun to study them than it is to study any other creatures. Well, this has been really interesting and a lot of fun, Dr. Gopnik. Really, thank you for joining me today. Well, it's always great to talk to you and to talk to all the APA listeners.
拜托，那是不可能是他们能理解的东西。而他们，你知道，就像两岁的孩子在几分钟内就做到了。所以我想，毫无疑问，他们会继续做一些真正令人惊讶的事情，这是我事先没有料到的，而我一开始就没有预料到这一点，当然这也是为什么研究他们比研究任何其他生物要有趣得多的原因之一。好吧，这真的很有趣，也很开心，戈普尼克博士。真的很感谢你今天加入我。很高兴能与你交谈，并与所有的APA听众交谈。
Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或您获取播客的任何地方找到往期的《心理学访谈》节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，请发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学访谈》由李·韦内曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪翁（Chris Condyion）。谢谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学协会。该剧集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。